coque blanche maison expert en relations
internationales revient sur la
controverse autour de la rencontre entre
le président palestinien et le ministre
de la défense israélienne
évidemment monsieur netanyahu a critiqué
cette rencontre puisque l'huile est
violemment hostiles à cette coalition
hétéroclite puisque elle a été constitué
d'abord sur la base de tout sauf cette
année où elle a été fait pour éliminer
netanyahu et elle fonctionne dans le
fond la surprise peut être de beaucoup
de gens parce que ce pacte comporte des
modes de confort de comportement dont on
vient de voir un exemple avec cette
réunion entre le ministre de la défense
israélien et monsieur mahmoud abbas ne
crois tu pas derrière tout ça il ya
aussi les américains puisque jack
sullivan est et à tête en israël et en
palestine et enfin ramallah il y a
quelques jours et il a certainement
encourager
mahmoud abbas et surtout le gouvernement
israélien allait dans ce sens peu hamas
reste totalement hostile à ce genre de
rencontres considère que mahmoud abbas
trahi la cause palestinienne
en faisant ce genre de négociations avec
le gouvernement israélien et c'est vrai
que objectivement ce genre de
négociation renforce namouh d'abbas par
opposition au hamas